Husband, if I
sleep in a place like this, I'll
get bitten by bugs.
Me, Tsukasa-chan.
Maybe I'm asleep. Look, it's
dark. Kyuma-
chan was found a long time ago. I see. Let's
go earlier than that. The
barbecue is about to start.
That's right. That day, as he was about to leave, I
desperately called out to him.
Hey Tsukasa-chan,
what did you mean that day, "I'll go out with you if you marry me?" Did
n't you say that? I didn't ask you.
Ah, that's right.  If
that's the case, then I'll keep it a secret.It's
really that bad.''I mean, I really
don't know why.When a
strange woman says something strange like that to me,
most people's response is, ``Yeah,'' and at
best they're silent or confused, or
at least
doubt it.  There are very few people who can give you an immediate answer.I don't know how
much of a creature I can trust, no matter what they say.No matter how many words I say, I
can't believe the other person.I doubt the other person's words.  That's why when someone
says something strange to me, I don't want to
ask.Even
if I don't believe the other person, I respond with compassion.I answered immediately, ``
Yes, be happy.''
That proves that I didn't doubt my words.My
words that made you doubt me.  You believed in it and took off.
No, but you just came out in a fit of excitement. That's
okay.
Even if it's foolish or sudden,
there are moments when you realize the truth.
[Music]
For example, when you propose as a surprise, the other
person's  Sometimes you can understand everything in a moment's expression.That's
just the way it is.The
answer is in a moment.The reason
I fell in love with you is because you believed in me first.You are
me.  Because you believed in me, I decided to believe in you too.
[Music]
Thank you, Nasu-
kun, Tsukasa-san. That day, I answered right away because I was
just happy that you turned to me. I was
just so happy, so
happy.  Still, I will be proud of the answer that day for the rest of my life.